johnny silverhand is the zac de la rocha
of the cyberpunk universe
a musician with a radical
anti-establishment message
johnny's a disgruntled veteran of the
1990s central american conflict an
anarchist
and most importantly the first rocker
boy here's the origins and rise to fame
of one of cyberpunk's most prolific
characters
a rocker boy is a class wholly unique to
creator mike pondsmith cyberpunk
universe
rocker boys and gals are charismatic
public figures
who speak up against the powers that be
they usually come in the form of
musicians like johnny silverhand but
they don't have to shred the guitar or
play an instrument to be considered a
rocker boy
according to pondsmith himself to be a
rocker boy you just need to be able to
eloquently
stick it to the man and convince your
buds to stick it to the man with you
man but rock boy doesn't have to be a
musician a rocker boy
can be anyone who's a orator of the
people
anybody who can talk to others
and convince them by the power of words
music sometimes art and so forth
although johnny silverhand is a 100 year
old rock legend in cyberpunk 2077 his
story begins in the 1990s during the
central american conflict a bloody
struggle launched by the united states
war machine to squash communism
unsurprisingly the united states had
ulterior motives there were important
resources at play that the united states
government wanted a piece of while the
us did a good job of keeping this a
secret from the general population
soldiers began to uncover the
government's underhanded intentions
many enlisted soldiers broken and
battered at this point deserted and
returned to the united states
among these deserters was one robert
john under
after losing an arm he returned to night
city with a red-hot rebellious spark
in his eyes after getting fitted with a
new arasaka design cybernetic arm he
changed his name
to johnny silverhand and formed a band
called samurai
the group consisted of carrie eurodyne
denny bes
isis formerly known as nancy and henry
you know
good old henry samurai's music was a
global phenomenon
the world knew who johnny silverhand was
and they heard his messages of rebellion
and revolution
loud and clear samurai criticized
government world leaders
and of course the mega corporations that
ruled the world
more importantly samurai's music lit a
fire under the general public
everyday folks were picking up
instruments and getting their message
out there and so
the rocker boy was born unfortunately
samurai came to an abrupt end when nancy
pushed her abusive boyfriend out of a
window and
killed him i say good for nancy but the
united states justice system
seemed to disagree and put her behind
bars shortly after samurai separated
johnny silverham kicked off his solo
career his first solo release was titled
sins of your brothers
if his work with samurai consisted of
vague lessons in rebellion sins of your
brothers overtly called out the
injustices of the central american
conflict
johnny's first solo album proved to be a
massive hit
not only did it sell like crazy but it
changed the world's perception of the
central american conflict and shined a
light on the united states imperialistic
practices
things were going well for johnny his
fame was on the rise and he started
seeing a woman named alteria cunningham
or alt for short alt an incredibly
talented netrunner created a program
called soulkiller that essentially rips
a netrunner's mind from their skull and
makes a copy of it inside a mainframe
the body
still alive is left to decay the good
times sputtered to a halt when arasaka
thugs kidnapped all to get a hold of her
soul killer program
johnny in a fit of rage devised a plan
to rescue alt from the arasaka building
with the help of thompson a famous
journalist with a distaste for mega
corpse
it's important to note that at this
point johnny hates
arasaka he already did to some extent
but now things are
personal i imagine he'll make his hatred
of arasaka
very clear in cyberpunk 2077.
i'm sure he also hates that shiny metal
arasaka arm he's rocking
with the help of his former bandmates
johnny silverhand puts on a free show
near the arasaka building to hopefully
incite a riot then johnny would lead an
assault on arasaka to save
alt just like when rage against the
machine performed at the democratic
national convention in 2000 a riot
erupted outside of the arasaka building
after samurai played a song titled chip
and in
fun fact swedish hardcore band refused
did an official rendition of this song
which you can listen to right now as
well as a few other samurai songs
johnny's crew with a crowd of 6 000
broke into arasaka headquarters
sadly they were too late alt was dead
and her mind was trapped in a mainframe
this particular section comes from a
story titled never fade away in the
cyberpunk 2020 rulebook we will most
likely visit this event in another video
but if you want a more in-depth look at
this key moment in johnny's life we
recommend reading the full story
after that johnny disappeared there were
rumors that the indomitable cyborg adam
smasher put a bullet in johnny but his
remains were never
found of course this isn't the last time
we'll hear from johnny silverhand
as his electronic ghost seems to play a
significant role in cyberpunk 2077
played by the illustrious keanu reeves
cyberpunk
there's a brief overview of johnny
silverhand's life and legacy there's a
lot more to this story but we'll have to
wait until november to find out more
in the meantime if there's a cyberpunk
topic you'd like to see us cover leave
it in the comment sections below and
make sure to tune in next week as
jean-luc breaks down
johnny's arch nemesis arasaka and with
that we'll see you next time samurai
backing down